parliament which is streamed on facebook
youtube and linkedin we'll be talking
today about the recent testimony of the
former facebook employee whistleblower
francis haugen yesterday here at the
european parliament who blew the whistle
a few months ago on
the company's practices
what they choose to how they choose to
disclose the data and on their impact
and use of technology on communities
around the world and more specifically
here in the european union and to talk
about this today i'm joined by crystal
chaldea moser and uh who is lead member
for the digital services act and andreas
schwab also member of the parliament and
responsible for the digital markets act
both of you work on important pieces of
legislation who which actually will have
a profound impact on the future on the
digital future of the eu before we start
i want to ask you to
of course put in your questions and i'll
try to ask as many as i can to my guests
so mrs mozilla start with you what was
your impression from yesterday's
testimony and uh
did you leave the hearing with us with a
sense of urgency on that something needs
to be done as soon as possible first and
foremost i think it was relevant for us
to to have her in the parliament and to
listen to
her experiences with facebook we are of
course making legislation that goes
beyond facebook it's not just facebook
but but i think it was relevant also to
to learn some of the business practices
we have we have seen from facebook for
me it was interesting it was useless and
not it was useful
and
and i took a lot of things away
most and
most
mostly probably the need to regulate the
need to do something to prevent the bad
practices we have seen from facebook so
i was maybe not happy but i was
satisfied with the hearing
and uh same question goes to you mr rob
this will have some sort of impact but
do you think this will impact also
moving forward to the way the parliament
legislate or do legislators already know
about these issues
no i mean there have been
rumors there have been
doubts there have been ideas but it was
quite impressive how this lady has been
outlining all the different business
practices
that are there
i want to say it like like that very
clearly that are there just to make
money
and it is in a certain way the normal
way of the economy but if you see um
that this is the only logic of companies
that have quite a lot of importance to
modern societies it's scaring
and we can do something and we want to
do something and we want to do the right
thing and i think we got very good ideas
yesterday but it's not the end
of the story there will be new practices
and therefore we have to make sure that
the laws that we are voting now are
future proof as we say that they can
also fix problems that come up in the
future obviously you both are working on
important pieces of legislation proposed
by the european commission uh and the
parliament is a co-legislator on on
these uh two um acts uh i want to but
before we get more into details on this
i want to ask you mr demonstrator you
previously have mentioned that these
revelations um will have an impact on
the the digital services act and thus
european users and facebook
specifically but also other platforms in
the near future
are these provisions in the proposed
digital services act uh enough to avoid
abuses
online
no
the proposal from the commission doesn't
in my opinion go far enough to solve the
problems we heard from francis haugen
but
parliamentarians here from the
parliament they have and myself included
have tabled amendments in order to to
try to fix it a little bit go a bit a
little bit longer the most important
thing uh here and now on the basis of
what she said is you know the algorithms
and the recommender systems from the
platforms they need to be
they need to they need to be
made
you know a trend we need to know what is
going on they need to be more
transparent and the platforms need to be
accountable for how they use uh the
algorithm so i i try to say it like this
you know i don't want them to be liable
the platforms for what you and me and
andreas put on our facebook
profile of course because it's our
content so they should not be liable but
the way they use our content the way
they recommend other users the way they
they work with it you know using their
algorithms they of course need to be
responsible and accountable for what
they're doing and here i don't think the
proposal from the commission goes
far enough here i think that
francis haugen gave us a good a couple
of good ideas on how to do it and and we
need to make them accountable so
if something goes wrong for instance she
talks about
young women
being exposed to
uh things on instagram that makes them
really uh have problems with their
mental health then of course i think uh
platforms should be liable so if
somebody hurts themselves on the basis
of that then of course they should be
liable so here i think or at least
accountable i think we need to to do
this indeed fascinating revelations
yesterday on on how this on how
platforms choose actually to to operate
with their algorithm but it's like the
wild west and at the same time it's
their business model so they act they
basically choose to
amend and adapt their business model
according to to the market and basically
that's how facebook chooses to to change
algorithm it is to a certain extent up
to them to to to change the algorithms
very often even we complain on why does
certain er
and that's the right of a business to
decide i'm just playing the devil
but that's true they have the right and
that's their business but if you take
the pharmaceutical industry or toys
industry or whatever
they are also have a business and they
produce uh drugs and and toys for for
for people but they still have a
responsibility and they ne they are
liable for what they are doing so we
have put in place for them legislation
on how we allow their business to to
take place and that is just what i want
to do also for facebook and other
platforms make sure that they have a
frame so that they know what they are
allowed to do and what they are not
allowed to do and besides that of course
they have to do their business
and an important proposal for the
commission is the digital service
digital
service digital market act
too much jargon
digital markets act if you could
simplify it for us what does it mean it
also uh includes rules on how uh
businesses operate on in the markets
correct and how do these two
legislations intersect with one another
well i i would say but this i i don't
want to intrude in the area of my my
colleague from denmark but i think the
digital services act is most of all a
procedural law to make sure that what is
allowed and what is not allowed in the
online marketplace is exchanged as
quickly as possible in between member
states and with the authorities
responsible to fix it
the digital market set on the other side
is a rather a law on market power
so it's not uh so much coordinating in
between the 27 member states of the
european union but it's looking most and
foremost on the biggest companies and
how they misuse
their market power to rule out
competition or to misuse dominance for
their own business interests
and this is not allowed in the european
union but so far we have not found the
best tools to fix it and with the
digital markets actually we want to
improve these tools we want to not
anymore wait for the companies to do
something which is forbidden and then
run behind them we want to tell the
companies listen you have to do this and
if you don't you cannot even continue
your business so we want to change the
burden of proof making the european
commission a much stronger regulator
in the area of competition policy as
they don't have to wait anymore for the
wrongdoing but they can
fix it already ex-ante so on beforehand
as we say
and i think this answers somehow uh to
the question of tommy who is uh
following us live on facebook uh who
says why is there only one facebook
meaning only one of its kind platform
why does one platform have monopoly uh
for this long what happened to
competition and having an alternative he
says uh i'm sure others tried to launch
um
well i think once there was a very good
idea let's say with google with facebook
and and i think crystal can also come up
with some insights what they do
to avoid competition but they have had a
very good idea and then they have had a
strategy to cover the market in all
areas and where they have been seeing
that the market is too strong and there
is competition they have just put money
on it
like that they have been covering they
have been buying small companies to
destroy uh competition they have been
investing into business models just to
take down others and there is this
famous proposal that i've just learned
today of fortu an app that was giving
some possibilities to create gifts
and ins they wanted to buy it one of the
gatekeepers wanted to buy this
technology that you can make your own
gifts and the company said no we don't
want to be bought we want to stay
independent and what they did they just
copied the business model and have
integrated into their and this is for
sure a very bad behavior it's forbidden
but it's a market power that is misused
and that we have to stop
but but you know
dsa and dma is interlinked because this
is the market power we need to solve in
the dma but still
we the things we're trying to tackle in
the dsa is this stands for digital
the platform legislation you could say
yes
is
we're in a situation that we cannot
do
what we really want to do in the
legislation because
the arguments i mean at least is that if
you regulate
facebook too much then the businesses
who uses platforms
sorry facebook's
ads services services ads they cannot
work because they become so dependent on
on facebook so that they don't have
other places to go and and and reach out
to their customers so in many ways
i think that this also shows the problem
we have today with some of the very
large platforms they have become so big
that they're too big to touch somehow
because if we touch them that will
affect companies using the platforms
services and in my opinion that is that
is a problem we need to have a better
competition we need to have a more
diverse
market so i hope that
andreas will solve that in in the dma so
we have a better market in the future
and more choices also for businesses to
to use to reach out to their consumers
and customers a market that is comprised
of 27
eu countries also very difficult to find
common ground
simple question do we have a common
definition on what constitutes hate
speech in the eu
no
no i mean
today we have
in many ways we have 27
different
ways of interpreting this
that's also why we try to not go into
harmful content but only illegal content
because already here it's it's different
and my favorite example is just to to
show that we have different ways of
doing this that in andreas home country
germany it is illegal to deny
that holocaust took place in my country
denmark
it is legal we don't like it but we want
it to come out in the open so we have a
chance to say to people and prove this
is not true look that we have
facts and things like that but for good
reasons it's banned in in germany and in
my country it's we we don't have the
same history so
that's an example that we have different
traditions different historical
backgrounds etc and therefore we also
have different ways of defining what is
illegal and what is not legal and and if
we should
broaden the scope and also say what is
harmful but maybe not illegal
then we have even a bigger difference so
it is difficult and therefore we still
have to keep also a structure where you
say that
the member states we cannot harmonize
every kind of aspect about what is
illegal in eu at least not now i don't
know what will happen in the future but
at least not now so we have to respect
the 27 different member states on on
this
but at the same time have a horizontal
you know have some common
uh obligations for for the platforms to
comply with and you mentioned germany uh
and francis howard yesterday she
mentioned germany as one of the examples
for example when facebook allocates
resources to the specific countries they
consider germany as top priority
especially during the elections and they
managed to allocate the proper resources
in order to mitigate hate speech and
especially this information during the
election campaign but in some countries
this is not the case because
language supports it requires human
resources and then don't allocate this
it harms also other democracies also in
countries outside of the eu so um
my question is as the parliament uh
heads into the eu elections in 2024 and
the tools to pollute this online
discourse with this information are more
sophisticated than ever um
[Music]
do you think that these digital
regulations will create some with
will provide some accountability
and responsibility towards the platforms
well i think the first the first point
of this example that you have been
choosing from yesterday's hearing is
that if we don't find the rules that
apply that are applied all over the
place together so in denmark in germany
and all over europe
then it's up to the companies to choose
what rules they will use as a pattern
and that will always be unfair
if they take the danish model we would
not like this in germany because we for
our history have
said that it's forbidden to deny the
holocaust
if they take the german model the danish
would not like it because they for the
freedom of speech principles they say no
everything what you can can be so stupid
that you can even not believe it but you
can say it so
the choice that we have to make is
somehow that it's a common european uh
value that we want to defend here and we
want to defend it all over the place
there are that little examples that we
have been focusing on now that are
different but apart from that all over
the place we want to have the same rules
and i think this is an important
principle and with that we can also
avoid that companies choose one or two
markets where they invest a lot and the
rest they forget like that we can oblige
them to invest all over europe the same
money to make sure that elections that
democracy and freedom of speech are
respect all over europe in the same
manner
but it's true that we have problems
today because if you have the bigger
languages facebook have more people and
more resources put into those languages
because bigger language also mean bigger
markets but for smaller languages we
have a lot of them in eu we are you know
maybe more you know
exposed to to to bad decisions from
facebook and let me give you an example
we have a famous danish journalist on
instagram and she she reported from
kabul's airport in august with
with the takeover of taliban and she
reported about it
but it was a kind of an anti-terror
reporting she was not uh supporting them
she was scared and she tried to report
that
but
instagram put down her
content content because probably she
showed a picture
of taliban
cheering and then you had the taliban
flag and that was
seen probably as terrorist content but
if they had real good language solutions
they would have been able to read that
this was in fact anti-terror content
supporting the fight against terror so
here it is important that we make sure
with common obligations throughout
europe that the platforms have to comply
with a lot of obligations among others
also to make sure that they have the
same safety requirements in place no
matter what kind of language you have so
we have a problem here and we need to do
something about it and hopefully that
the bigger platforms will also by the
end of the day comply better if they
have better tools and better more
languages in place but it is a problem
well if they can detect uh certain
languages they can do it with other
languages and yesterday was this was
also the discussion
in their statement
facebook cruiser door miss haugen said
that the dsa the digital services act
has a potential to be a global golden
standard it has to be strong and its
department has to be firm and end of
quote are we on time to ensure that
regulations this goes to both of you uh
brought into force would bring about a
global standard on the online world such
as like the gdpr one did for instance
well i mean we were some years ago with
the internal market committee in in
japan
and japan for example has taken over the
european legislation on cyber security
i was lucky to be the rapporteur on it
and on general data protection why have
they taken it over because the
principles
of the democracies are more or less the
same
and the rules that we are setting
are becoming respected by the companies
that deal with it and then it's much
easier if other companies countries in
the world take
advantage of our legislation but for
this our legislation has to be very
very good to be very blunt
and very practical and i think somehow
we are struggling with that
on the digital markets act i think we
can for sure make sure that competition
is a basic value
and this basic value is more important
than ever because only open
economies
allow open societies to exist only in
economies where all people have the
feeling that they can make their
business work where they can make their
innovation a reality only in such
societies democracy can grow and we have
open societies that's what we want to
defend in europe and if we do it well i
think it could also spread uh over
europe and i think it's the same for the
digital services act crystal no yeah
well i i do believe that
if we do it right we will set the
standards globally
in in many ways rather simple you know
if we put up obligations for platforms
with
when they work in europe
targeting european uh users then of
course
they would
they would probably also you know copy
paste it for their services
many other places in the world
or
some countries will
want to copy what we do so that they
have the same kind of protection and
with the dsa we're trying to make up a
rule book for how platforms can work
and we want to give users no matter
whether you're a business or a consumer
buying goods or you know
a citizen expressing your point of view
you need to have some rights and that is
what we're trying to do and i'm sure
that other countries around the world
will follow
maybe not as fast as as we would prefer
but i'm sure that it will be
some it will set standards globally if
we do it right and if we do it fast
okay
let's believe in goodwill and i believe
it personally but uh sometimes there are
also controversial views like that the
one from eric
who says on facebook that we should stop
bashing companies that we should help
companies and not go against free market
is this the case here no but we help
companies but we help all companies and
not only one or two and there is plenty
of companies that are suffering
from unfair behavior of a few
and our aim is to make sure that there
is fairness in the market as much as we
can assure it
and so we help companies we haven't
spoken about those companies that we are
helping we have only spoken about others
but eric can be relaxed we want to
defend business practices in the
european union to continue to operate
we exactly want to defend the companies
that have to use the platforms and we
want to have a better
level playing field so that they are
still in business so we are really
defending them i am defending them and
andreas are defending them
uh
i
miss kalimos do you think the ds the
digital services act will make tech
companies disclose the way they choose
to extract personal data so for example
it was mentioned yesterday by the miss
hogan that uh
the way companies choose to is the way
they interpret choose to interpret it
but for example they are not asked how
they extract the data for instance
do you think i know it's very specific
and maybe it's too detailed for now but
do you think we should go to this
direction and make companies disclose
all the way they extract data and they
share
and obviously share
like make create an obligation for them
to share this data with uh with
authorities yes definitely authorities
definitely authorities absolutely i mean
if we if we have a legislation in place
we need to be able to see whether they
are complying with it or not so they
need to reveal this for at least the
authorities
maybe all to researchers
and and maybe even the public to a
certain extent maybe not business
secrets but still i think that they need
to to show more of what they're doing
but but we are working on it and let's
see where we end it's still a little bit
too early to say whether we will be
successful on this because we still have
to finalize our position in the
parliament and after that we have to
negotiate with the council
so we don't know what the final outcome
will be but
stay assured that we rest assured that
we will do whatever i will do whatever
it takes to make sure that we have a
well-functioning
legislation in place
mr webb you mentioned previously in a
previous statement the digital the
digital markets act
will make sure that personal data can
only be used for political advertising
if users give their renewed consent and
that weight can never have a cambridge
analytica 2.0 very bold by the way
for where personal data is abused for
political gain
how do we make uh how do you ensure that
this does not happen again and what sort
of oversight does this legislation
ensure and to what extent do you think
it will companies be made to disclose
the data they they uh possess
well i mean first of all what we cannot
do in one or two laws is to fix all the
problems so therefore on the political
advertisement and all the risks around
that
we wait for the european commission to
come up with the proposal in november so
at the end of this month
where they want to come up with specific
solutions on this and i think it's
important because our elections have to
be neutral political
parties have to have their own messages
not being misled by platforms and more
importantly
positive
and balanced messages should not be
neglected and only radical and extremist
positions coming out and this is a huge
problem that we are at the moment faced
with in political discussions if you are
just saying i want to have a world where
people understand each other no one will
care about that tweet if you say we have
to fight that we kill all the others
then the the tweet or the message will
be seen that is not a good word in real
in which we are living on at the moment
and that is something that we have to
address and we hope that the commission
come up comes up with proposals on this
what um concerns the question on how to
make sure that
the information that especially the big
platforms are having
we have heard yesterday
that for example 80 percent of
misleading information on kovit has been
coming to four percent four percent of
the users so the problem is that you
have a certain number of people only a
small portion but they get all the
misleading information and for sure they
are
it's too much for them to check all that
so we have to make sure that what is
good scientific practice is somehow
shared all over the place and that all
parts of the population and all users
get a bit an information about the
normal life so that you don't end up in
a bubble that is very delicate because
it has to do with freedom of speech and
chris is discussing about that every day
this is very complicated because freedom
of speech means also that you can decide
yourself to listen only to stupid stuff
but if a platform is pushing you there
that would be the wrong choice if you
choose yourself no one can stop you
we've heard recently that
some facebook staffs tried you know to
to to see how fast you uh ended up in
these rabbit holes you know where you
only received recommendations for uh you
know conspiracy
theory pages etc and it lasted three
days
and then they were in this rabbit hole
and this is clearly facebook's
responsibility to make sure
that you don't end up in these kind of
rabbit holes with you know no way to to
come out of it again
and with no balanced uh you know
information so they the platforms will
have to take a responsibility to make
sure that they are
you know
using their algorithms and recommended
systems in a way that don't uh
ruin our democracy and that gives people
balanced information
and and i and i think that they have to
do more than they're doing today and
hopefully our pieces of legislation will
be a little step in that direction and
more will come later on from the
commission and then hopefully some
uh
common sense also will
uh
come into facebook sooner or later you
know i think they are afraid of their
business and i think that they are
looking into how to to do things better
maybe they should start
looking into how their algorithms works
what francis haugen told us was they are
doing this because they earn money they
want us to stay on the platform as long
as possible and in order to make sure
that happens they have to recommend us
things where we get engaged involved and
very often that is bad things you know
because then we become angry
commercial yeah controversial things
then we are
working because then they know then we
click and and and and spread the news
and so they have to do more and and we
need to push put a pressure on them to
do more to avoid this meaningful
interaction says facebook
uh
do you think that's the case also when
it comes to political content
you as politicians are present on social
media
you've seen certainly your your content
going down because facebook is putting
more uh resources to and uh and more
focused to to meaningful content uh
between people and friends uh and groups
uh but that has is is basically taking
people into these so-called um echo
chambers so do you think that uh this
sort of um
[Music]
this first
this legislation being brought forward
also this testimony yesterday
here the parliament will help
raise alarm
well it helps to understand better some
elements that we may have not heard that
bluntly before
so for example the point that i was just
making before was something that i
haven't heard ever before
i think it was also impressive that it
was very professional the presentation
of all the elements
um
but we have to understand that in the
united states there is a very strong
let's say economic battle of shareholder
value companies
that want to gain more money this is not
forbidden but it's up to the lawmaker to
set the frame in which this is possible
and i think in europe we have really to
come up with stronger and more clear
rules to make sure that we are not in in
such areas where that the freedom of
speech is important that political
parties play or well where we are
speaking about the common good
that this is misused for
money
making practices
we have to discuss bluntly but the best
argument has to win and not the worst
case that makes most money
any timeline before we end this
interview on the digital markets act
well i i hope that we can vote in the
plenary in december
and then we will see the french
presidency how we can come to an
agreement
and i'm very hopeful that we can not
only do it on the digital market sect
but also
with you know will we have a digital
single uh digital services act before
the european elections in 2022 i
certainly hope so
but i don't dare promising anything
good i hope so i hope so we all want uh
um a healthy conversation on social
media although we cannot eliminate
completely hate speech and
disinformation uh thank you very much
for being here and i hope to have you
again to discuss about this as soon as
possible uh thanks to everyone who
followed this live we'll be back with
more lives if you want to follow
yesterday's testimony of facebook
whistleblower francis haugen you can go
down our feed on facebook and thank you
to everyone who followed also from
linkedin and youtube have a nice
afternoon
you